ça sent le gaz pour les pissenlits ils
disparaissent un à un carbonisée aux
propane dans ce parc de Guyancourt
depuis 5 ans la communauté
d'agglomération de 50 ans en Yvelines
prône le zéro pesticide plus de produits
chimiques mais l'huile de coude comme
ici avec le désherbage au gaz le poids
élagué lui se retrouve en copeaux dans
les massifs
de la matière organique nécessaire au
développement des plantes les copeaux
retiennent l'humidité donc la plante
avait besoin de moins d'eau et les
mauvaises herbes ont trouve moins de
support pour se développer en mettant
dans les déco mais ces différentes
techniques sont forcément moins
efficaces les mauvaises herbes
réapparaissent plus rapidement et ce
n'est pas le seul inconvénient c'est un
surcoût effectivement qui est
principalement la main d'oeuvre
supplémentaire pour passer plus souvent
mais là encore il faut intégrer qu'on
est en système écolo
et donc on a tout intérêt à le faire
à peu près en
pourcent
50% de plus un surcoût que
l'agglomération digne d'avoir pas
ressenti et qui n'a donc eu de
répercussions que pour les entreprises
sous-traitantes au total 650 hectares de
parc voirie et à bord de bassin sont
concernés
les pollueurs en milieu urbains sur les
jardins et bien ce sont les services les
collectivités ça ne se passe vers des
collectivités et puis en partie les
particuliers question de santé publique
l'agglomération s'est voulu précurseur
les mairies elles commencent seulement à
s'y mettre